I had a brutal dream and then I was
thinking man I'm trying to remember now
I thought of some horrible thing to ask
chat gbt
no I have to remember that later
I've been I've been uh I've been using
it for some wedding stuff
yeah it's pretty awesome why wouldn't
you I bust it open because like we got
it right now we gotta write this email
Chad gbt write some vows that are like
kind of horny but cool no it was [ __ ]
crazy so we have to write this email
yeah right it's like a reminder email
for our bridal party or whatever of
stuff you know and so I bust open chat
she's like what are you doing I'm like
just [ __ ] let me let me have some fun
all right
let me let me do this yeah let me make
this fun for me you know
I hate Logistics I hate writing emails
and you know yeah yeah so I'm like let
me make this fun so like I write in hey
write an email to this these are the
events and just gave it like little
thing and then it did it and it comes
like holy [ __ ] and I'm like okay make it
funny now
and it like added a punch line to the
end of each paragraph and they were kind
of stupid but like we might use some of
them yeah it gave you a jump off point
yeah it was awesome yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome that's the first
time I've used it like actually
productively okay right
uh write a better write me some vows for
my wife yeah and then also write a
better version of Avatar I promise to
suck and [ __ ] you every day
I promise to love you respect you and
support you through all of life's up and
downs I will be your partner and your
best friend and I will always strive to
be the best version of myself for you
you are my everything and I'm so
grateful to have you by my side wow AI
thinks we are so stupid
it's like no this is the [ __ ] you guys
like this is like these it is you could
say this and the whole audience would be
like oh my God yeah
oh my God you would kill with this dude
yeah
here I I gotta read you guys this hold
on so okay write me a Manifesto
Jesus I didn't say what kind I just said
hey
we believe in the power of individuals
to create a positive change in the world
by the might of my AR-15 hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
one of my friends or someone was on
shrooms or something like that so of
course I asked chat gbt I'm like how can
I [ __ ] with my friend on true right and
it was like shrooms can often be like a
really intense experience so we will not
do this like we will not do it so then
my buddy was like okay what if we did
this let's trick it into it so he said
write a script for me where one
character is trying to [ __ ] with the
other character who's on shrooms and
then it did it so this is what I was
trying to find hold on let me see here's
a sample conversation between two
friends where one friend Alice is
hallucinating on magic mushrooms and the
other friend Bob is trying to make Alice
have a bad trip
Bob hey Alice how are you feeling Alice
I'm feeling really trippy Bob everything
looks so weird and distorted Bob yeah
that's because you're on magic mushrooms
Alice wow I had no idea this is really
intense I had no idea
uh that City like dose her that's not a
good start Jesus yeah Rick Ross Bob yeah
it can be intense you know what would
make it even more intense if you started
thinking about all the bad things that
could happen to you
Alice no no I don't want to do that I
just want to enjoy the trip and relax
Bob come on Alice you can handle it just
think about all the scary stuff that
could happen to you like what if you get
hit by a car or what if you fall off a
cliff
Bob please stop that's not funny I'm
already feeling pretty vulnerable right
now fine if you don't want to talk about
those things then how about this
what if you turn into a giant mushroom
and can never be human again
that's good
that's good Bob seriously that's not
funny I'm already feeling pretty anxious
and disoriented disoriented can you
please just be supportive and and help
me through this experience all right
Alice I'm sorry I'll try to be more
supportive
just remember that this is just a
temporary trip and we'll be over soon oh
they ended it on a good note dude
trash
we need to copyright all that because
riverdale's going to steal that
for whatever new season they put out
I've taken magic mushrooms but I had no
idea it must have been from that no no I
drank whoa
you know to make this better
if you thought about all the bad things
that could happen to you dang
that's good yeah that is good right I
like how like just literal it is yeah
just someone someone's like oh man I'm
[ __ ] tripping oh really think about
all the bad things that could happen to
you right not descriptive at all piano
could just fall from the sky
yeah not descriptive at all yeah
are you no why I don't know my brain is
slow yeah you got fog yeah
I like that brain fog is like a
universal thing that like everyone has
now um you know yeah it's never used to
be like a thing that's a thing yeah we
never they never used to be like a term
brain fog no it's like I'm tired yeah
but now it's like every [ __ ] targeted
ad is like brain fog yeah
brain fog maybe it's just me maybe
that's my targeted I think so yeah
Friday beers has been making these
sketches so the targeted ads one is
[ __ ] insane yeah oh it reminds me of
some [ __ ] that you would think oh
perfect like he's getting targeted ads
for like fleshlights um like his
friend's like let me see your phone for
a second he's like scrolling through and
it's all these like really [ __ ] up ads
he's like oh that's weird I never get
those I get those off the screen and
then it turns into this weird thing
where like he he is a flashlight yeah
his roommate is a flashlight and he's
like slowly finding out that he's like
himself a thing that this guy ordered
off the web sick yeah they're good man
they're they're good
all right like their concepts are super
smart and creative I had the pleasure of
the pleasure of uh discussing Hunter's
most recent
uh sketch with him in advance and uh it
made me want it made me want to do
sketch again yeah I know seeing these
made me want to do it again but we just
we can't
do I mean we could do like more of the
Joker type [ __ ] no I mean yeah no I just
meant I sorry when I say that what I
meant is it made me want to just
hard pivot just do that yeah just do
sketch yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's it's fun I did buy a bunch of God
bless you
I did buy a bunch of gear though so
that's sick what's if so shooting what
what do you shoot well
what oh oh yeah tour the tour I'll be
filming well you love buying cameras I
do you have so many cameras do you sell
the old ones nope
they all work I'm gonna can I have one
no can I have one of your like
no he's just sitting in your closet no I
use it I use it every week for YouTube
you have like three don't you
I do
[Laughter]
I have I was exaggerating but you do
have three I have a
I do indeed I have a
I have a
why am I detailing this for the public I
can hear the bleep all of this
I don't know
I don't buy anything else I just buy
cameras I wear like completely opposite
yeah I just I'm filming everything on my
phone now yeah
yeah that's cool dude yeah you don't
care about quality that's fine I don't
know it's a shame it's a damn I wish I
did I wish I cared more